now but you know what maybe women should
have an equal say because you know we we
we give life right right King we we
bring life to the world so isn't that
valuable to a society we bring life we
bring Purity oh no we do not what up
guys welcome to the just early things
YouTube channel and welcome to my
whiteboard Series today I'm going to be
doing part two of why women shouldn't
vote so if you guys saw my appearance on
Pierce Morgan you'll see that argue that
women should not have the right to vote
and I also have a whiteboard video where
I explain um why I don't think women
should have the right to vote now part
of this is because women do not offer
the same value to society as the whole
point of feminism is to say men and
women are equal so the men offer equal
value to society as women now and I
think that this premise is just false it
cannot be true now you might think Pearl
that's sexist don't you hate women why
why would you want to take the right to
vote away from yourself I start to look
at the numbers so first of all women
didn't even want the right to vote only
5% of women even wanted the right let's
let's take the anti-suffragists out of
it and let's just look at the value
added to
society so now what is value added value
is output in a way all right so the
definition of value is the regard that
something is held to deserve the
important Worth or usefulness of
something so how useful are women to
society is the question now the first
question is should we give privilege
based on how useful someone is to
society I would say yes I would say yes
now a lot of people say you can't
measure value but I really think you can
so couple stats so men run the
infrastructure of society they pay the
majority of the taxes so a common
complaint I got was like Pearl well then
a lot of men shouldn't vote what percent
of men even do those job so I looked it
up for you out of the kindness of my
heart okay so if we include cuz you know
we have to Define what is the
infrastructure so I included farming I
included manufacturing I included um
transportation um I included building
the buildings Paving the roads uh the
jobs that mostly men do and a small
percentage of women do all right so
13.7% of men have jobs that are
associated with the infrastructure
either public or private sector
construction Power Water roads but not
including truck drivers and other
transport so I would consider truck
drivers necessary I live in a city how
would I get food without my truck
drivers so if we include truck drivers
and Farmers we need food right that goes
up to 24.4% amend then if we add mining
workers and Associated field workers it
gets to
26.2% now what about Factory workers how
did this get constructed how did all the
stuff we have in this apartment get to
construct factories so that goes up to
35.9% of men then if you think about
protection we think about protection
electricity Plumbing manufactured goods
we go up to
35.9% and if we include the military
police and firemen we got 44% of men
that work in running the infrastructure
of society so one in two men is that not
do you think that's significant or is
that insignificant is this okay now
remember women do teaching we do nursing
but if those jobs went away the
infrastructure of society would still
run we would still have food we would
still have water we would still have a
military 44% so almost one in two men
run the infrastructure of society so
there are some beta ass YouTubers that
are like well I I stream I'm just a
streamer maybe I shouldn't maybe I
shouldn't vote by this logic well if you
don't employ anybody I might say yes and
this doesn't even include the men that
run the Fortune 500 companies and
business owners because if you include
that those are people that hire people
because women tend to have smaller
businesses men tend to have bigger
businesses so so okay 44% of men what
percent of women run the infrastructure
what percent do you think 0.5% it's
higher than you think so for the
women it is um seven .
69% of women run the infrastructure of
society and that breaks down 2.81% comes
from Factory workers um infrastructure
workers is 1.78% and police staff 1% do
we really believe the female police
officers are as needed as the male ones
are they really going to hold us down if
hits the fan infrastructure workers
the plumbers and electricians are they
really are they holding the sign are
they holding the flag lag for
construction on the side of the road or
are they the ones really doing it come
on guys be honest be honest the first
part of running the infrastructure of
society men do more so men here so men
do the harder jobs in terms of value now
you know what maybe maybe maybe the men
like the women we're just starting to
out earn men and make all this money
maybe we're paying more taxes right
wrong wrong men pay more taxes they pay
they pay 60% of the taxes but maybe wait
they pay 60% wait how did they said they
pay 60% more tax than women okay well
maybe women are just better than with
money right maybe women we I mean we may
not make as much but we're just more
responsible they always say women mature
faster than men so we're just so much
more responsible wrong wrong wrong we
hold 2/3 of debt so we make less money
we do the easier jobs we have more debt
now but you know what maybe women should
have an equal say because you know we we
we give life right right King we we
bring life to the world so isn't that
valuable to a society we bring life we
bring Purity oh no we do not so the
birth rate has dropped below 1.64 kids
per women so less than two kids a chick
and they're projecting that 50% of us
are going to be single and childless so
only a we're no longer 95% of us aren't
virgins on our wedding night so the
majority of us we don't bring Purity to
the market we bring more debt we do the
easier jobs knowing all this information
can we really say that men and women are
equal that we contribute equally to
society why should we have an equal say
now I am open to suggestions guys it
could be net taxpayers because by that
logic still men would be the majority of
the voters um it could be only the men
that are only the people that are in the
military or the infrastructure can vote
which would also lead to men voting the
majority my point is why do we get the
most say when we do the least amount of
work women you cannot win an election as
a politician without catering to women
you have to get the female vote and the
majority of the Swing voters are single
women so now we have all of the
politicians catering to women who don't
offer equal value now you can say that
maybe as a woman I shouldn't advocate
for this but I think we should advocate
for a society that is fair and the way
this is set up women are doing the most
useless jobs we have the majority of the
debt we're not having children we're not
getting married and yet we want an equal
say to men but I don't know guys let me
know maybe I'm wrong maybe Pearl's just
a misogynist I just hate women and I'm
just a dummy YouTuber doesn't know any
according to these beta ass simp ass
reaction channels who don't look at any
of the numbers behind the so let me
know what you guys think in the comments
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next
time as I was saying men pay 60% more
tax so what does that mean about the
total tax that women and men pay now I'm
going to be honest I don't really
understand this math King did it he's a
man they they do this stuff but women
only pay 20 % of the tax total if you do
the math but men pay 60% more now you
could give or take 10% but again so if
men are paying the majority of the tax
is this fair is this Fair